the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hello and welcome to 507 biochemistry
online I'm dr. Bob danfa delish despite
the staggering biodiversity we see in
nature the types of chemical reactions
employed are only but a couple of
handfuls and these are used over and
over again very efficiently and with
conserved mechanisms as I recall from
organic chemistry one of the most
versatile chemical groups is the
carbonyl C double bond o not
surprisingly carbonyl chemistry is well
represented in biochemistry in fact the
carbonyl chemistry allows formation of
carbon-carbon bonds is one of the very
few ways in which enzymes can start with
small molecules and put them together
into a macro molecule or start with a
macro molecule and break it down into
smaller pieces during metabolism this
video summarizes some of the most
important carbon yield reactions you
will encounter in 507 in this video
we're gonna be talking about carbonyl
chemistry and as we will see carbonyl
chemistry is fundamental for some of the
carbon-carbon bond formation and
cleavage reactions as you recall from
organic chemistry carbonyl contains a C
double bond o and all the properties of
the carbonyl derive from its ability to
polarize this bond so that can draw a
resonance structure where the carbon has
a positive charge and a oxygen and
negative charge as you recall there are
simple carbonyls such as aldehydes
and ketones also we have a so derivative
compounds in which the carbonyl is
attached to a hetero atom X can be
oxygen nitrogen sulfur
so here respected we have esters amides
PI R esters and of course we have an O
its group here carboxylic acid sure is a
summary of the reactions that we're
going to be talking about first I'm
gonna be discussing the chlorophyll ik
addition here a good nucleophile react
was the carbonyl adding to the carbon of
the carbonyl and generate this
tetrahedral the compound next we're
going to be talking about utilization
this is the property of carbonyls that
contain an alpha hydrogen which can
rearrange to form you know next we're
gonna introduce the aldol reaction this
is the reaction in which a carbon-carbon
bond is formed in a curse between a
carbonyl that acts as an electrophile
and it utilizable carbonyl which acts as
a nucleophile in the aldol reaction a
bond is formed between these two carbons
generating and aldo we're also gonna see
that the l dolls can dehydrate aldo saw
above can lose a water molecule to form
an alpha beta unsaturated carbonyl now
about the acyl derivatives we're gonna
be talking about acyl transfer reactions
where an acyl derivative
can convert into a different acyl
derivative with the appropriate
nucleophile in a variation of this
reaction is clean reaction where
similarly to the aldol reaction we have
an enol izybelle carbonyl reacting was
an acyl derivative and generating and
beta keto parvenu
this reaction also forms a carbon-carbon
bond which is right
let's talk in more detail about the
nucleophilic addition the general
reaction scheme is as we saw before
here is a carbonyl compound reacting was
a nucleophile in forming a tetrahedral
intermediate that contains an alkoxide
or an alcohol now let's take a look at
two different reactions one is the
reaction of alcohols with carbonyl
compounds where we form a compound that
looks like this this is called a
hemiacetal now this reaction is
reversible and in fact it reaches
equilibrium because Delta G naught is
approximately zero this reaction can be
both acid or base catalyzed let's take a
quick look at the mechanism if it's base
catalyzed
the base will first deprotonate the
alcohol which will form the alkoxide
which is then a very good nucleophile to
attack the carbonyl we forms this
alkoxide version of the hemiacetal which
can be been protonated in acid catalyzed
mechanism we have to activate the
carbonyl first so the protonation of the
carbonyl is the first step all right so
this activated carbon you can then be
attacked by our alcohol
which this product is just one proton
transfer away from our hemiacetal
alright the second reaction I want to
include here is the formation of shift
basis which is the reaction of an
carbonyl is an amine similarly to the
hemiacetal formation this reaction
generates first a tetrahedral
intermediate which is however unstable
and loses water to generate the amine or
the schiff base let's take a look at the
mechanism as you notice the reaction
because the amine group is a good
nucleophile the reaction could occur
even in neutral conditions but we don't
need necessarily acid or base catalysis
the first step the amine attacks the
carbonyl forming this compound of split
charges now proton transfer happens
generate our intermediate then water is
eliminated
and this is the amine now notice that
amine nitrogen can also be protonated to
generate this iminium ion which as we
will see in in other situations
it's an activated version of the
carbonyl group from these two examples
we can get some idea or how the
nucleophilic addition occurs so let's
take a look at what kind of nucleophiles
we can add to the carbonyl group we have
some good nucleophiles and here we have
things with negative charges such as
alkoxide or hydroxide I have the title
aids and other things such as amines and
we also have some ok nucleophiles and
here we have alcohols even water and
tiles as you saw in this couple of
mechanisms the ok nucleophiles don't
react very well unless the other
deprotonated to form good nucleophiles
such as the alcohols or the carbon eel
gets activated either by protonation in
a strong acid as we saw here or it's
becomes an activated carbon for example
in an iminium ion another important
nucleophiles that we're gonna see is the
what we gonna call a c- basically a
carbon ion in our case is gonna be
enolates which can also add to the
carbonyls and these will form the basis
for the aldol reaction the second
reaction we're going to be talking about
is inhalation here a carbonyl that
contains an alpha hydrogen can rearrange
to form an enol we're going to call this
the keto form and this the enol form an
equilibrium between a keto and enol form
it's called polymerization and this is a
very important reaction in many
biochemical systems turns out the Delta
G for the reaction as written it's very
high 30 to 50 kilojoules per mole that
means that equilibrium strongly favors
the keto form however in certain cases
the you know can form and get stabilized
the mechanism of analyzation it's very
straightforward all we need is a decent
base that can remove the alpha proton
and it will form this enolate now you
know that it is able to form because it
has resonance stabilization we can draw
another resonance structure as such
where we see the negative charge is on
the carbon so is in fact a carb anion
we're gonna call it a disguised carbon
and as the carbon is not very
electronegative
having sun such a high electron density
on the carbon would make it a very good
nucleophile and in fact this enolate is
the nucleophile that executes reactions
such as the aldol reaction and the
claisen reaction something to keep in
mind
well how acidic is this alpha hydrogen
so we can compare it with the hydrogen
in an alkane the pKa of such a hydrogen
is close to 50 it's extremely hard to
remove a proton now if we look in the
alpha hydrogen next to a carbonyl the
pKa is 18 to 20 so it's 30 orders of
magnitude more acidic
and this is because as we saw when we
removed this hydrogen will form the
enolate anion which is resonance
stabilized a more extreme case of this
if we have two carbonyls alpha 2 the
same proton the pKa drops even further
around 9 to 11 this is because we can
draw even more resonance structures to
the enolate that's formed this is one
this is another
and another
as we saw before the charge here is
delocalized between the oxygens and
alpha carbon so it is this beta keto
carbonyl and it's in a light form will
behave as a carbonyl and it can act as a
good nucleophile
the aldol reaction this is a very
important reaction biochemistry because
allows formation of carbon-carbon bonds
or if the reaction lands in Reverse
cleavage of the carbon-carbon bonds the
alder reaction is the reaction between
an enol izybelle carbonyl as we show
here a carbonyl that has an alpha
hydrogen and another carbonyl and what
happens is a new carbon-carbon bond
forms between the alpha carbon and the
carbonyl carbon the product of the aldol
reaction
it's called aldol as a contraction
between aldehyde and alcohol as in some
cases this carbonyl be an aldehyde and
this will be an aldol it's essentially a
beta hydroxy carbon you know this
reaction has a Delta G not close to zero
that is it reaches a very reaches at
equilibrium and it can be catalyzed by
acid or by base let's take a quick look
at the mechanism given the previous
mechanistic insights we looked at at the
nucleophilic addition and enol formation
then the mechanism of the alder reaction
should be fairly straightforward if it's
base catalyzed the base is gonna help us
form the enolate
as such and as we discussed previously
the enolate is a good nucleophile and
can react via nucleophilic addition was
the the other carbonyl and one proton
transfer to generate the aldol product
the reaction can also be acid-catalyzed
again formation of the you know in acid
catalysis involves first protonation of
the carbonyl now this activated carbon
it's much more electron sink and
stabilizes the enol formation now in the
second step the enol can react who's the
other carbonyl degenerate protonate a
version of the aldol which is one proton
transfer away from the aldol product
in biochemical systems the enzyme that
catalyzes the aldol reaction is is
called aldolase and there are actually
two kinds of all the lasers class one
and class two the distinctive features
these enzymes is the way that catalyze
the reaction class one uses an active
site lysine to perform a shift base with
the carbonyl which activates a carbonyl
and allows for the enol formation class
to use it's a metal ion such as zinc to
accomplish the same thing so here is how
their mechanism for the class one
aldolase would look like so here's our
analyzable carbonyl and here is our
active site lysine and as we saw before
an amine reacting was a carbonyl will
give us a shift space the reaction goes
viana tetrahedral intermediate which I'm
not gonna draw here but what we form is
this iminium ion now the carbonyl is
activated enough that an active site
base can remove alpha hydrogen to form
the you know which is now
well-positioned to attack the other
carbonyl
this generates the aldol product in its
amine form still attached to the enzyme
and now the hydrolysis that you mean is
going to release the Alba now class two
enzymes use a zinc ion as the ion
approaches the carbonyl it's going to
draw some of the electrons from the
carbon you and make the proton in the
Alpha position a lot more acidic
so you can imagine some of these
electrons get delocalized so that a base
can remove the proton and form the
enolate which in a second step it reacts
it's a carbonyl which will generate the
aldol product in the active side of the
enzyme still bound to the zinc and now
which can dissociate and generate the
final and release the product now very
important consideration for the aldol
reactions there's again a core in the
reverse fashion for example to cleave a
carbon-carbon bond so the bond that will
be cleaved as we see here is the bond
that got formed which is the bond
between the Alpha and the beta carbons
aldolase is one of the key enzyme in
glycolysis that allows us to break a six
carbon sugar into three to three carbon
sugars by cleaving a carbon-carbon bond
via the aldol reaction as the mechanism
catalyze but aldolase we can see that
the reverse pathway is pretty
straightforward where the aldol binds to
the enzyme saying class one informs an
active side covalent interaction a shift
base was the lysine from which the
chemistry occurs to break the
carbon-carbon bond and leads to the
release of one carbon eel marco and then
the other one would be still bound to
the enzyme as a shift base and
hydrolyzed for the class to the aldol
will interact with enzyme by forming a
interaction was distinct and this
activates the carbonyl allows the
chemistry to occur exactly in the
reverse manner as shown here
one other reaction involving L dolls is
aldol dehydration here's an aldol beta
hydroxy carbonyl now if an aldol has an
additional of hydrogen it can lose a
water molecule to form an alpha beta
unsaturated carbonyl now this reaction
is favorable thermodynamically Delta G
naught is approximately 0 and this is a
reaction we're gonna see in in a lot of
biochemical pathways for example in the
biosynthesis of fatty acids going left
right or in the catabolism of fatty
acids going right to left
here's a quick insight on the mechanism
once again it can be base or acid
catalyzed this reaction works because
the Alpha hydrogen here is next to a
carbonyl and therefore can form an enol
so if a base can remove this hydrogen to
form the enolate then we can envision
how this electronic movement will allow
for a water molecule to be eliminated
forming our alpha beta unsaturated
carbonyl
the acid catalyzed mechanism goes along
the same lines as you remember in order
to form the enol in an acid catalyzed
the context first we have to protonate
the carbonyl all right now a base can
remove our alpha hydrogen forming the
enol which can kick off water molecule
generating this pieces which is just one
proton transfer away from our final
product
so let's talk now about acyl derivatives
and acyl transfer as we mentioned acyl
derivatives have a carbonyl attached to
a header atom this header atom can be
oxygen nitrogen sulfur as all these
header atoms contain a lone pair of
electrons one of the key property of the
acyl derivatives would be a resonance
between the header atom and the oxygen
now the properties of the acyl
derivatives will be dictated by how easy
or how difficult it is to adopt this
minor resonance structure in other words
how likely is for the header atom to
participate in these electron
conjugation let's take a look at a
couple of ways of derivatives this is a
carboxylate if they had our atom is in
nitrogen we have amides if they had her
atom
it's oxygen we also have esters or
carboxylic acids and when the hitter
atom is sulfur we have tile esters the
order in which I wrote them here is not
actually random it turns out for the
carboxylate because he has already
negative charge the ability to adopt
this resonance is greatly increased so
it's very well resonance stabilized the
ability to perform these resonance
structures it's also great for amides
and this dictates the the chemistry and
biochemistry the amide bond which is
explored in greater detail when we talk
about protein esters can also do and
adopt these resonance structures however
tyo esters because the sulfur is a third
row element so the p orbitals or sulphur
are much bigger they don't overlap very
well was the p orbitals of the carbon
the ability to adapt these resonance
structures is greatly diminished
therefore esters behave a lot more like
ketones where the electrons of the
carbonyl bond are localized between the
carbon oxygen and not so much between
the carbon and sulfur
so therefore time esters are the least
resonance
and this is the trend and this trend
universally correlates was the
reactivity carboxylates our least
reactive
whereas testers are the most reactive no
when we talk about acyl transfer we'll
talk about the reaction between an acyl
derivative was another nucleophile which
will replace that X had an atom was the
Y hetero atom this reaction always
occurs via a tetrahedral intermediate
when both substituent's are attached to
the carbon now from here this digital
intermediate can fall apart by kicking
off yr to regenerate the starting
material or it can kick off the XR group
to generate a new piece of derivative
let's now talk about
claisen reaction this is a very
important reaction about chemistry
related to the aldol reaction in which
were form or cleave carbon-carbon bonds
the claisen reaction happens between an
enol izybelle carbonyl and an acyl
derivative let's pick in this case an
ester and during this reaction a
carbon-carbon bond is formed between the
alpha carbon of the analyzable carbonyl
and the keto carbon of the ACE of
derivative the product of the claisen
reaction is a beta keto carbonyl let's
look at the mechanism as wizalll
carbonyl reactions when we form a
carbon-carbon bond we need to form an
enolate so this is the first step a base
will form removed alpha proton in form
to enolate
which is now poised to add to the a so
derivative in an acyl transfer reaction
forming first tetrahedral intermediate
which can spontaneously fall apart by
eliminating they had her atom group to
form our beta keto carbon eel products
now in biochemistry a preferred software
for claisen reaction is at io ester one
of the most common theaters were going
to encounter in this course is a still
Chloe Chloe or coins I'm a it's a tile
that conformed pilasters was a lot of
acids for example acetic acid in here a
Sudoku a can undergo a claisen reaction
was itself and therefore acts both as a
utilizable carbonyl and as an acyl
derivative from um we're talking about
Taiyo esters because they're limited
conjugation was a carbonyl
they are very reactive and they allow
the formation of the enolate
here's the a steel koi inulin which can
react with another I still Kuwait
molecule and will generate a tetrahedral
intermediate
let's Rogers molecule first which can
lose one of the Kawai molecules to
generate this beta keto time ester Osito
acid dil KO e as we will see later in
the course this is a precursor to
formation of ketone bodies one of the
ways in which a still Kawai can be used
to store energy now what is coenzyme a
often abbreviated co a we mentioned it's
a tile
it's a tile that means it has an SH
group which it turns out is on a very
long linker
there you go this is coenzyme a you
might recognize this part of the
molecule as being adenine bound to a
ribose bound to two phosphates it's
essentially adp and but notice there's
another phosphate at the three prime
position so it's an ADP was a three
prime phosphate this portion of the
molecule
if you squint resembles the amino acid
cysteine but without the carboxyl group
and this middle portion of the molecule
it's something that looks very difficult
to synthesize notice this carbon that
has two methyl group attached and two
other carbons attached to it so it's
like a tetra valence a carbon attached
to four other carbons that's a fairly
rare sight in biochemistry this portion
of molecule is called pantothenic acid
pantothenic acid is an essential
nutrient also known as vitamin b5
in this video we talked about carbonyl
chemistry carbonyl is the C double bond
o and a lot of these properties are due
to the polarizability of this bond where
the carbon has a partial positive charge
in oxygen partial negative charge we
talked about reactions symbol carbonyls
such as nucleophilic addition you know
ization aldol reaction and the aldol
dehydration and acyl derivatives where
the carbon units next to a hetero atom
such as oxygen nitrogen or sulfur and we
mentioned the acyl transfer reaction in
the claisen reaction we saw in this
video the nucleophilic addition where a
nucleophile attacks the carbon of the
carbonyl to add informant turkey drill
product for example alcohols can add the
carbon ester forming hemiacetals and
amines can have the carbonyls to form
amines or shift basis and we reviewed
that good nucleophiles are the ones like
alkoxides
violates amines or c - enolates whereas
okay nucleophiles like alcohols and
tiles they need to be activated first to
undergo a nucleophilic addition I also
talked about inhalation the ability of a
carbonyl was an alpha hydrogen to
rearrange into an hydroxyl bound to a
double bond which we call an enol now
this equilibrium called tautomerization
favors strongly the keto form however it
does form the sufficient extent to allow
chemistry to happen for example when we
remove the Alpha hydrogen we form an
anion called enol eight which is a
disguised carbon ion which is a very
good nucleophile
next we discussed the alder reaction a
very important carbon-carbon bond bond
formation or cleavage reaction in
biochemistry this reaction happens
between analyzable carbonyl and the
regular carbonyl and a new carbon-carbon
bond is formed between the alpha carbon
and the keto carbon is shown here the
mechanism can be both base catalyzed and
acid catalyzed and the enzymes that
catalyze this called Aldo laces use
either a lysine at the active site to
form first a shift base or they use a
sink in the active site to polarize the
carbonyl and allow for the enol
formation we also saw that aldol
products can dehydrate to form alpha
beta unsaturated carbonyl the mechanism
could be both acid and base catalyzed
and involves in both cases formation of
an enol next we also talked about acyl
derivatives and acyl transfer as we show
here the resonance in the acyl
derivative is is the dictates there how
well they react carboxylate and mi is
the most resonance stabilized in the for
at least reactive whereas esters by
especially tyo esters the least
resonance device and therefore most
reactive finally we discussed the
claisen reaction every action similar to
the aldol between analyzable carbonyl
and a nice little derivative which
generates a bitter keto carbonyl we
introduced a still Kawai a very
important entire ester that kind of go
claisen reaction was itself to form
acetyl CoA and we also introduced the
structure of koi which is built around
vitamin b5 an essential nutrient